Hi Youtubers it's Charlie!  So this week
marveled just announced
sweeping changes coming to the Marvel
comic book universe
most hardcore comic book fans are really
pissed, but
I wanted to explain how the movies has
started to influence
the way that they think about the comics.
It's not completely responsible
for why they're changing the Marvel
comic book universe, but it has something
to do with it.
Quick explanation of what's going on
Marvel is rebooting
their comic book universe. It's like the
train is stopping at a station
a bunch a comic book readers will hate it,
totally get off the train
a bunch of new people new people will jump on. They'll use
it as a point to start reading the
comics.
They're starting with the whole new
continuity after their big Secret Wars
comic.
Secret Wars is the name of the big story
line it's gonna run this summer.
If you never read comments before I'd
recommend checking it out if you
if you don't want to pay for comic, if
you don't have money, you can get Marvel
Unlimited its super-cheap,
and six months after it comes out you
can read it for almost free.
Mostly it's meant to clean house. The
Marvel Universe in the comics is just
all over the place
there's so much going on there's so many
changes that have happened and now they
have all the movies
in its like this billion dollar industry.
They wanna make things line up, so
they're just taking an opportunity
to make it all sink up a little bit
better. That doesn't mean that the comics
are going to be exactly like the movies
or the move is going to be
exactly like the comics they'll always be
largely independent
it just that they'll make character back stories
the same. You'll see more characters from
the movies
appearing in the mainstream comics. It
will also help them side step some of the issues
with like multiple versions of say like
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch running
around in the movies and TV shows.
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch are just the
best example like there's
X-men movie versions their characters, and there's going to be Avengers versions of their
characters. It's really confusing so
Marvel is just trying to clean house little bit. One of the best ways to
explain that in in the bases this video
is Avengers: Age of Ultron. You have the
movie coming out in a couple months
we're all really pumped for it, but there's also
a comic book Age of Ultron
from 2013, from a couple years ago. The
story that they're gonna do in the movie
in the story that they did in that comic
book, completely separate.
Have absolutely zero to do with each
other. So just looking explain things a
little bit better
careful for spoilers from the Age of Ultron comic book story from 2013.
In an alternate reality Ultron's taken
over the world using a for a time travel
in the process of fixing things
Wolverine shatters the space time
continuum
creating a separate time line. That's
partly responsible for the craziness
that's going on in the Marvel. So the movie
as you've seen is only have like a
fraction of the number of characters
from that comic book and the story's
gonna be way way simpler.
So like all the crap that happened to
the Avengers in the comic book
Age of Ultron has absolutely nothing
to do with what's going to happen to the
Avengers in the Age of Ultron movie.
It's just a good example of how the comics
have always been completely separate
from the movies,
TV shows, other media so all that
separate but equal stuff changed a
couple years ago.
No more segregation in the Marvel
Universe, at least on the surface level.
After the first Avengers movie came out,
it became proof that on the corporate
level
you can plan in movies out this far in
advance and it'll work it's a good,
financial model.
And then you side step to companies like Fox
who are trying to do the same thing with
the X-Men universe.
So Marvel and Disney are adjusting
things again, now with this new big comic
book reboot to bring everything a lot
closer.
Make it simpler to follow, and make it fit
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe
just a little bit.
That doesn't mean that the comics are
gonna be exactly like the movies.
Like I said, there will just be a little bit more
continuity with the character back
stories
based on the IP that Marvel owns across
film, print,
and TV. And really at the end of the day,
what's happening is
is you're seeing original characters
from the movies ending up
in the mainstream comics. Agent Coulson
is is the first example of that, the first
big example.
Normally it would flow in the opposite
direction but you have a comic book
character
that ends up in a movie. Just this year
though, they started doing comics
based on the TV shows, so there's an
Agents of SHIELD comic book,
featuring the characters from the TV
show. If it's successful, it's an ongoing
comic.
if it's successful they'll probably do the same
thing with the Peggy Carter show, with aging
Agent Carter.
They did do an original side tie in comic
with her and Howard Stark, like a story,
but is not an ongoing comic. I have been
reading the Agents of SHIELD comic. It is OK
like
but if you don't have enough money to
buy new comics all the time, just get
Marvel Unlimited
and read it six months later and you can read
it for almost next to nothing.
Like it's almost free, seriously. The latest
big example
at the movies influencing the comic
books is
a couple
ages they made to the Quiksilver and
Scarlet Witch characters, so
just minor spoilers for Avengers X-men
Access
for that comic book story line. So in the
comic book, I mean it's mostly a Red
Skull story where he makes
shit go crazy as a result to that, it's
discovered
the Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch are not
Magneto's true children.
That was a huge retcon a big WTF but you can
see why Marvel might want to make the
Quicksliver and Scarlet Witch
of their comics closer to the version of the
characters that they're doing in the
movies.
They're never going to get the X-Men
characters back just based on the
contract that Fox has with X-men I P.
As long as they continue to make X-men
films, they can keep making
X-men films indefinitely. So Marvel is
banking on the fact that they're never
going to get X-men back.
So just to make things less confusing
for people that might read the comics in
the future
they wanna make the Quicksliver and Scarlet Witch characters seem more like
the characters the people see in the
movies, because nowadays it's the movies
that are really driving comic book sales.
So what you have, is you have like a lot of
people who've never read a comic before
go see Avengers: Age of Ultron and they'll
say, 'Hey I wanna read about these
characters in the comics."
Then they'll go out and look for them but they'll have these
really complicated back stories that
have absolutely nothing to do with the
characters in the movies.
So Marvel, just trying to make things a
little bit simpler. That's like on the on
a minor scale.
The big universe reboot they're doing,
that's more but a specific comic book
thing just to make their continuity
lineup.
They just have the multiverse, and  they had so
many different versions the characters
they just wanna make it simpler.
And there also just taking the
opportunity  to bring the movies
and the comic books just a little bit
closer. Most the changes Marvel's making
won't really play out until Secret Wars this summer. So
I'm gonna wait to give anything thumbs up,
thumbs down until after I read some of
those new comic book titles with the new
continuity.
They're gonna keep making the movies no
matter what; they'll keep making the comics
no matter what.
So worst-case scenario you just bail on
the comics for a couple years till Marvel
reboot everything again.
Seriously Marvel/DC  they change their comic book
continuity
a ton of times over the years. They're
gonna keep doing it. Like I said, the
people that will be affected by this
most are the people
that had been reading comics, like a
lotta comics, for the past like 20 or 30
years.
So it'll be a bit of an adjustment, but if
you're a huge Marvel fan
then eventually you get used to it. It'll
look a lot more like the DC Universe
does right now.
Not not in terms of characters and I'm
not trying to
imply that they're going to make the
characters look like the DC characters,
just in the way that the universe
works, like a shared continuity.
I think a lot of people are just worried
with Disney taking over Marvel
and trying to make everything connected,
it's all gonna get homogenized and
watered down
and everything look the same. Here's my big
question for you guys, do you cared that
they're completely changing the
continuity the Marvel comic books
and do you like that they're trying to
tie it into the movie just a little bit
more?
You know, I mean it's not gonna cross
over directly, but the characters will
shared some continuity in terms of  back
stories.
So moving on to Marvel related stuff, I
know a lot of you guys have requested Black
Panther videos so I think my next video
will probably be like a Black Panther
character video.
He's gonna be one of the big movies, Marc
Guggenheim, who is this show runner on Arrow,
was even joking how he wanted to
write the script for that.
I don't know that he would have time to
do that because being a show runner
on a show that shoots over 180 days a
year is like the full time job for two
separate people crammed into one
person's job.
In case you didn't know, he's actually
married to one of the show runners on
Agent Carter.
So you have like a lot of Marvel DC
under the same roof Although Marc Guggenheim,
himself
does write a lotta Marvel Comics. If you
do have any other like special request
for
Marvel videos just let me know in the
comments, in a couple weeks
Constantine will go away. I have a little
bit more time in my schedule like
you know Fridays through Saturdays at
least until Game of Thrones get here.
So we'll have some opportunities to do
some other bonus videos, some other fun
stuff, that I don't normally do.
So while you guys wait for my next Marvel video,you
can actually click here for my last Q &A
I go a little bit deeper into the Ultron trailer. Talk about
like you that mystery person might be. And
you can click here for my
top 5 Ultron stories from the comics.
Thank you so much watching.
So let's all high-five. I'll see you guys this weekend.